[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I would like to think that I have a wide
taste in anime not just one of those
instant gratification types who aren't
satisfied unless there's a fist sinking
into some space or entire forest being
wiped out by a single powerful misguided
fart every five minutes so I do like to
give every I'm a chance to take that
switch in my brain called enjoyment
before condemning it into the deep Tar
Pits running that's which Menace boredom
I say this now because as high as I've
tried I've never been able to get into
the school life toner it's not that I
haven't tried to like it I force-fed
myself as much school I find amazed my
stomach its sake but with the exception
of great teacher Onizuka none of those
animes ever did - flick that switch so
when I first heard about the melancholy
of haruhi suzumiya I mean he dismissed
as another generic high school comedy
now I know some people say never judge a
book by its cover but I like to say or
judge an anime by its fan base like how
the Naruto fan base consists of yeah PPP
Wesen [ __ ] pissing around pretending to
be a very loose definition of the word
ninja or like how the Evangelion fan
base is made up of pompous pretentious
[ __ ]
who'd like to attack enemy newbies with
power of nerds and convert entire
[ __ ] essays on the metaphorical
meaning which induce little pinky from
what I noticed Harry he had a fan base
of an otaku crazed mush comprised
primarily of fan goes that communicate
solely through high-pitched squeals and
fanboys who have completely lost the
concept of dignity I spend their spare
time fantasizing about how to count
girlfriend with a name that doesn't end
with thought jpg
I just didn't want to become one of
these fanboys so it was at this point
that I decided to disregard it thinking
I was popularity just blow over the high
would eventually die out and the fanbase
would finally realized that they were
worshipping a six in your fictional
school girl two years later when his
popularity still going strong I finally
gave in and watched it like it's
innocent char being peer pressured into
trying his first cigarette before I've
been watching a series I had the dilemma
of choosing to watch it in the
chronological order or the bizarro order
of the broadcast version but even could
be the average person before Rossum's
common sense
I immediately opted to watch in the
chronological order with it being the
most logical choice though a little bird
told me otherwise because apparently
somewhere along the line the series got
pissed one I woke in the middle of
someone's backyard I forgot that I had
any common sense to begin with as far as
the story goes it was the miscellaneous
adventures of Kyo Mickey
Yuki and Koizumi in the undercover
mission to save the universe from total
destruction by keeping Harry key from
becoming Bors that's about the gist of
it anyway there was something about
aliens Time Traveller's and Esther isn't
it but anyone who says they're watching
Harry he for the completely ridiculous
plot sorry bad boys but it is it's just
lying the best episodes in this series
were the ones that didn't have anything
to do with the main book like the rock
concert baseball or video game episode
or maybe for that and for a certain
dance but I'll get back to that later
from what I can tell the entire series
is set in the mind of your typical anime
geek
I mean seriously it's not a studio I got
together a small group of otaku and
asked them to make a list of what they
wanted in an anime series with the list
being comprised of school girls space
battles rock concerts pani girls pre B's
fanservice fanservice [ __ ]
fanservice
okay I'll eye has done that much
fanservice in the Lupino sense of
attempting the rate of one record of the
number of times PBS and panties can be
flash across the screen in the space of
one episode but there is a lot of
fanservice in a sense of the whole
series is basically made for fans Kyoto
Animation obviously knew who their
target audience was and played it so
well that they managed to ensnare the
fanbase into liking it
maybe that's why there are so many hair
Akif and was up there perhaps it's just
an addictive thing wait you know I mean
an addictive thing okay let me rephrase
that
I think what I was trying to say in my
very limited way there was that Harry he
just has a way of drawing you to its
world but it just Rosen you and slowly
develops into a whole new scary type of
addictive thing and as much as I thought
I would be saying this
I enjoyed Harry key well hots of it
anyway so I could never shake the
feeling that I was just trying too hard
to impress me it's turning together just
about every anime John it together up
excellent in just 14 episodes and I got
the impression I think that you know why
wants it to be now I don't think its
review would be complete unless I
mentioned the Harry had a youkai dance
since that seems to fit at all these
days I don't know what Kyoto Animation
to have with their crazy opening and
endings but I put the Harry Harry Yuko
dance in the same place I put a lucky
star opening up my metaphorical arse I
mean yes it is an extremely catchy song
and a wonderfully animated dance but
those are the things I hate about it now
since after watching one too many people
were tempted odds with your life it now
reminds me less about hyperactive school
kids choreographing a wacky dance and
more thick nerds making themselves look
like complete wankers
overall Harry he said he was a surprise
package and deftly wasn't what I
expected
there are many high points in it but at
the same time there are many episodes I
just did get the first episode almost
put me off the series completely since I
got the same impression for the episode
as I did the lucky stuff and we all know
what I thought about that in the end you
will probably find something that you
like in this series the trouble is
actually having the patience to find it
I still don't think it's as good as bass
pro games but still good nonetheless and
maybe the reasons that so many Harry he
found boys exist isn't cause of the hair
or the dance but maybe because we all
have a deep repressed desire to secretly
become Harry's [ __ ]
or then again maybe not overall I give
this on me an 8 out of 10
[Music]
[Music]